good afternoon you're the best behaved
class i've seen in yours it's all silent
and precisely to
assign time
come
here
trade by biology class i'm tom pollard
i'm dean of the graduate school
and uh this is part of our accompanying
scholars lecture series this year our
speaker today is beverly gage
who is a specialist on 20th 20th century
uh political history
beverly is a yale college graduate 1994
with a bachelor's degree in american
history and i'm a live academy she's
been a really really good student
in 2004 she received her phd from
columbia university
uh in history again
and with the station
in 2004 she joined the yale faculty and
the history department listened to the
ranks and was relying on small
professional tenure in
uh 2012.
that's how i got to know everyone a lot
of other young faculty members i serve
on the promotions committee and i was
really excited about the work she was
doing specifically
she's going to talk about every day
apparently has a teaching prize here and
distinguished result as well by having a
public presence because she appeared
regularly uh in the public key on the
pbs newshour
to the general public and her areas of
interest
she's published one book already
on an event that i didn't even know
occurred but was interested to learn
about in 1920 there was a terrorist
attack on wall street she wrote a whole
book about that as a first example of
terrorism in the united states
she has another book that she's working
on
it's going to be available in a couple
of years apparently with a little bit of
luck
on
hoover and that's the uh topic of our
lecture here this afternoon and i'm
particularly interested in this topic
because when i was growing up in the
1940s and 50s
was some kind of a mysterious scary
mythical figure in our society who i
really didn't understand i didn't
understand why he had so much power
like some people were so enamored
and my other people were afraid
and beverly's gonna help explain that to
us here today thank you
all right well thanks to dean pollard
and to the graduate school to all of you
for coming out on this
cold cold day i am in fact going to be
talking about j edgar hoover and about
this book that i'm writing right now
about j edgar hoover
and that actually was a sort of perfect
introduction in ways that i don't think
that dean pollard even quite understands
because the two themes uh in fact of
this lecture are
how did j edgar hoover get to be so
powerful and
who the heck actually liked j edgar
hoover
during his lifetime so i'm going to
actually start out with a little bit uh
up here on powerpoint for most of the
talk i'm just going to be here talking
i'm going to talk for maybe 30 40
minutes and hopefully leave quite a lot
of time for a q a but to start out i
have exactly
two slides and really three images that
i wanted to present
so when most people hear the name j
edgar hoover these days one of two of
these kinds of images come to mind
so over here we have j edgar hoover and
if you can see him so he's holding a gun
although hoover himself was uh never
much of a shot though he had lots of
pictures of him holding a tommy gun he
was never much of a shooter himself uh
but he's also holding a torn
constitution in his hand and down around
him you have all of the people whose
lives he destroyed in the process of
tearing apart the constitution
socialists union leaders black leaders
native americans third parties and i
think this is one of our two dominant
images of j edgar hoover at the moment j
edgar hoover shredder of civil liberties
particularly destroyer of uh the
american left and much of what's been
written about hoover has been in uh sort
of the vein of understanding civil
liberties and their violation uh in the
20th century
the second dominant image at the moment
this is of course when you tell people
you're working on j edgar hoover this is
the first question you get is the
question
about the dress uh and about hoover's
sexuality so this is actually a cartoon
these are a bunch of fbi agents over
here this is a cartoon that came out in
the 1990s and they're saying you know oh
if only j edgar this is a time when
there were scandals about the fbi lab
and its inefficiencies
and they are saying you know if only j
edgar hoover were alive we wouldn't be
having this kind of image problem um and
then here's hoover uh wearing uh ladies
stockings and high heels coming dancing
around the corner and then they said oh
wait a minute i take it back
and this image of hoover as uh both a
kind of repressed gay man potentially a
cross-dresser
certainly was the dominant image of the
movie that came out last year the movie
j edgar starring a creepily aging
leonardo dicaprio
and that movie really focused on
hoover's relationship with his second in
command the associate director at the
fbi clyde tolson
i'm going to talk a little bit about
that and there's lots more to say about
that in the q a but to start out here i
actually wanted to present
a third image which is an image i think
that contains its own set of surprises
at this point
in the context of what we know about
hoover i'm actually going to at least
attempt here to show
a one minute long video and i might even
ask you for your responses when this
video is over um so i want to set up a
little bit of what we're seeing here so
you probably recognize this fellow
richard nixon who has his own uh
complicated past and complicated history
as well which we can talk about but this
is richard nixon at the very end of his
first term
at j edgar hoover's funeral on may 4th
1972.
so a couple of important bits of context
before you watch the video itself
at the moment that hoover died he was
still the director of the fbi and at
that point he had been the director of
the fbi for 48 years
became director of the bureau in 1924
when he was 29 years old and he died in
1972 at the age of 77
in the same job
his extended career at the justice
department was actually even longer than
that he entered the justice department
in 1917 i began really working
intensively with the bureau in 1919 and
as i said at the age of 29 became its
director so had this 55-year career at
the bureau or at the justice department
of which 48 were
as director of the fbi
so that's one piece of context second
piece of context
is this man up here richard nixon
and hoover and nixon had a very
interesting and long-standing
relationship they met
working together on the alger hiss case
when nixon was a new congressman in the
late 1940s and really provided each
other with a lot of political support
and with i think a genuine friendship at
least of sorts throughout the 1950s and
60s though they uh came somewhat to
blows
once nixon was president nixon had
actually said at certain points that he
thought he might try to fire j edgar
hoover and then he backed down and
basically chickened out and failed to do
so but so there's a long history between
hoover and nixon at this point the last
piece of context to just give you a
sense of this kind of mystery
fear to some degree but also reverence
that surrounded j edgar hoover at the
moment that he died in may of 1972.
at this funeral the previous day hoover
had actually lane in state in the
capital in the capital rotunda he is one
of the only civil servants aside from
your military leaders and presidents
he's the only civil servant ever to have
been given that honor um and when nixon
goes to give hoover's eulogy at his
funeral at the national presbyterian
church
television stops all three networks
actually broadcast j edgar hoover's
funeral live and so what we're going to
do is just watch a small clip of uh
of nixon here giving j edgar hoover's
eulogy in may of 1972 and then i'll talk
about why i think that's important
will not die
the profound principles associated with
his name
will not fade away
rather i would predict that
in the time ahead
those principles of respect for law
order and justice
will come to govern our national life
more completely than ever before
because the trend of permissiveness in
this country
a trend which edgar guber fought against
all his life
a trend which was dangerously eroding
our national heritage as a law-abiding
people
is now being reversed
the american people today are tired of
disorder
disruption and disrespect for law
america wants to come back
to the law
as a way of life
all right
so there we are so i'm curious if anyone
has an immediate uh reaction to that
that uh clip that they want to share
either people who
remember j edgar hoover from their own
earlier years or
i have my own thoughts about why that's
important but does anyone have
other thoughts yeah it's just funny to
think of 1972 that then americans would
come back to law as a way of life it
seems like a funny moment to make that
claim
and you have to imagine that the
audience had something in mind anybody
thought would have agreed with that but
it doesn't seem like a particular moment
of
anti-violence in american history so
it's interesting what he was inferring
about the order that the structures of
bureaucracy brought about
okay
right this is absolutely true so may
1972
uh hoover dies june of 1972 is the
watergate break-in and actually i'm not
going to talk about this a lot in my in
my talk then maybe we can get to it in
the q and a um i think there's actually
a pretty good case to be made that
watergate would not have played out the
way that it played out if j edgar hoover
were still alive i actually wrote an
article about this so i can tell you
about that if you're curious at the end
of any other reactions just yeah it
doesn't sound like a eulogy to me it
sounds like
um for example okay yeah so it doesn't
sound like a eulogy and of course this
is the middle of the 1972 campaign um so
that may be part of the reason that it
doesn't sound like a eulogy um but
there's i think a little more to be said
about that any other just immediate
reaction
right right so this is coming at a
moment when uh certainly kind of
anti-war protest has been building and
building for many years
nixon has become mired in this
and hoover has uh you've seen the first
exposures of the fbi's campaigns against
the anti-war movement as well so maybe
we'll take these two last ones yeah
for those of us who are working here at
yale in that period
nixon had been
absolutely intent on
pushing dissent
down underneath and and i know that
hoover helped him in that in that part
so you have a it's an irony that he
stands up there saying how much you want
it when the fact that he was imposing it
as best he could
right so the idea that they are actually
uh claiming to stand for law and order
while at the same time suppressing
dissent and we have one last one here
and also just what i was hearing in that
it was i mean that was
what what hixon said there was very
briefly the
embodiment of the kind of law and order
conservatism that was the reaction to
uh the perceived disorder from those of
late 60s early 70s
civil rights movements assassinations
protests against the vietnam war sexual
permissiveness
that really led to this
conservative movement that was i think
at least
based on this
right so we also have the theme of kind
of the the the birth or i would say the
extension of what was referred to then
um and now uh as in i want to turn that
on as law and order conservatism um so i
think we've actually already hit upon
many of the uh let's see what happens if
i close that will that just go to sleep
all right well i'm going to leave that
up there because i'm not showing a lot
more
a lot more slides for the moment there's
nothing too distracting there right okay
um
so i also wanted to show that clip and
i'll just throw out my three reasons
that i think it's striking to look at so
one uh is
the fact that j edgar hoover in that
moment had a funeral like that right had
a funeral
that stopped all three networks and that
he had that kind of power and influence
not only within washington but as a kind
of cultural and political icon um the
second thing that i think is
particularly compelling to me which is
what um a lot of people seem to have
seized on here maybe the title of my
talk was a little bit suggestive in this
sense um is in fact the fact that j
edgar hoover stood for something and
stood for something that people
recognized stood for a particular kind
of politics stood for a particular kind
of political language and stood i think
uh for a certain kind of uh complicated
political hypocrisy
as henry was suggesting but i think it's
more complicated than simply saying
hoover
claimed to be defending the law at the
same time that he was breaking it uh the
third thing that is particularly
striking to me about that clip is in
fact just how much j edgar hoover's
image has changed since that moment as i
said we have now these kind of two
dominant icons of him one of him is this
kind of unadulterated villain of civil
liberties uh one as um this kind of
laughing stock the butt of jokes uh or
at the very least this story of him um
as a kind of repressed and sad man who
is playing out his kind of psychosexual
situation on the national stage and i
guess what i'm trying to do in this book
that i'm writing is to take hoover again
away from these kind of marginal images
of him uh these images in which he's
this kind of rogue figure in which he's
this one-dimensional villain in which
he's the butt of jokes and bring him
back into the place that he occupied for
better or worse in 1972 and for much of
his career which is at the center or
maybe the center right of american
politics
and that's really what i'm going to talk
about today
the question that in many ways is going
to drive my talk today and i think
drives my own kind of intellectual
relationship with this project is the
question of how it is that a man who was
outspoken and ideologically conservative
maintained the level of power and
influence that he did in the period that
we generally think of as the great age
of american liberalism right as we
narrate our politics in general the
period from the 1930s through the 1970s
was exactly the period that hoover had
his greatest power and influence we
often talk about as the great age of
american liberalism particularly at the
federal level so how do we put these
pieces together how do we want to think
about hoover as simultaneously an
ideological conservative and someone who
exercised an enormous amount of state
government power during this great
liberal age um so that's really the
driving question as i said both of my
book in terms of american politics and
in terms of my talk today um before i
get into sorting out some of the pieces
of that
i just thought i would say a little bit
more
about the book itself and about the
kinds of challenges that come first with
writing a biography um and secondly uh
with writing a biography of a man like
jay edgar hoover
so i first encountered hoover as tom
suggested uh when i was writing my first
book which was
about a bombing on wall street in 1920.
you were not the only person who had
never heard of this event in fact the
impulse behind my writing that book in
the first place was that i had never
heard of that event and i came across a
little mention of it this was when i was
in graduate school and i thought wow how
strange people were bombing wall street
in 1920 and having fairly high numbers
of casualty which seemed like an
interesting way into
telling a story about ideas about
capitalism about wall street about
resistance to capitalism and wall street
and also about uh terrorism as a form of
political violence that it turns out has
a very very long history in the united
states
but in the course of writing that book i
came across this young man who was there
at the then very tiny bureau of
investigation within the justice
department only had a few hundred agents
who was back there
both beginning to keep files on
political radicals
and also was largely running the
investigation into this bombing his
initials are everywhere on those
documents
and he was really the behind the scenes
guy though he was not then the head of
the bureau
running that investigation and his name
was j edgar hoover
what this meant i think for me was two
things so first i was surprised to see
hoover there uh playing such an
important role and expressing at that
point uh in 1919 and 1920 so he's about
24 years old at this point expressing so
many of the ideas that are going to
follow him throughout his career
particularly ideas about anti-communism
about the need for law and order in the
united states
about the threat of subversion within
the country i mean he's really there
just had the bolshevik revolution and
he's there very very early on
articulating these things thinking about
these things and really rising through
the federal government as one of the
architects of the way in which the
american state thought about these
things it was very striking to me how
early that started and i'll talk a
little bit more about why that's so
striking uh the other thing that
happened in the course of doing that
research was that i was forced to read a
lot of literature about j edgar hoover
and in the course of doing that i
realized a few things um the first was
that a lot of it is not really very good
uh that hoover is one of these uh
figures who tends to attract a lot of uh
obsessive kind of conspiracy theory
approaches um so there's a lot of
literature actually which i now have to
plow through because some of it actually
has some
some useful material there but a lot of
what had been written about him had been
written by journalists had been written
by amateur historians so he was someone
who sort of occupied a lot of interest
but there wasn't a very well developed
literature about him at that point to
the degree that sort of serious scholars
serious historians serious journalists
had taken hoover on
a lot of that tended to fall into one of
two camps that literature
during his lifetime much of it was
incredibly agilatory and i'm going to
talk a little bit about the ways in
which hoover was very good at
cultivating journalists
giving them material so that they would
in fact
write
books in particular that would reflect
his own world view um and after his
death almost all of it has been kind of
counter mythical you thought j edgar
hoover was one thing actually it turns
out he's this other thing and if you
look at almost all the biographies of
hoover they contain the words the
secrets of j edgar hoover official and
confidential but they're really about
kind of taking down the myth of j edgar
hoover as it um
sort of occupied the american political
sphere for many years
the third thing that i noticed about the
literature on hoover is that a lot of
the best stuff had been written in the
1980s and 1990s and there's a very brief
period from about 1987 to 1993 when all
four of the major biographies that exist
of j edgar hoover were written in very
quick succession uh all four of them are
actually quite good and have um sort of
different uh different takes on hoover
bring different material and different
themes to the fore but they were all
written in a particular moment there was
sort of a generational moment in which
hoover had died in the 70s you began to
get access to the files in the late 70s
and early 80s and then boom you got this
rush of books that attempted to define
hoover and for the most part were
written in this kind of vein of expose
the fact that it had been about 20 years
since a biography of hoover meant a few
things so the first thing that it meant
was that in terms of materials 20 years
is a lifetime for the kinds of materials
that you tend to deal with when you're
writing about someone like j edgar
hoover
right he is not the kind of figure where
you get to uh find out where his papers
are right this is how historians work
you find out where his papers are kept
and then you go to that library and you
sit down and they're all there and
they're kind of arranged in folders for
you
and you make your way through this this
body of files
in order to write about the fbi most of
this work has come through the freedom
of information act
and so some of that stuff is now public
and is now publicly accessible in an
easy way other researchers
have uh have also made their files
public but it's a pretty slow process
it's a pretty laborious process
and so it means that as time goes on we
begin to get more and more and more and
more of this available as more and more
researchers begin to think about doing
this so over the course of 20 years
there's just a whole world of new
material that had come out just to give
you one particularly dramatic example
at the time that the last set of
biographies of hoover were written the
soviet union was more or less still
intact as i said the last really major
biography came out in
1993.
since the fall of the soviet union we've
had access not only to soviet archives
which have told us a great deal about
communism and anti-communism
particularly espionage in the united
states but we have also found that the
soviet union had the records of the
american communist party which we now
which have been missing for many years
uh the early records of the american
communist party we now have access to
that and we have access to things like
the vanona documents which was a secret
espionage project
that the fbi in conjunction with the nsa
had conducted uh in the 1940s and had
kept secret for many years in which they
were uh decrypting
soviet diplomatic cables um and this has
shed all sorts of new and interesting
light on some of the most famous
espionage cases of that period including
the uh the alger hiss case that i
mentioned
so that was the first thing that it
meant that there was this whole wealth
of new material that was out there
another quick example just since we
already mentioned watergate um is the
fact that we now know that mark felt who
was hoover's third in command at the fbi
was deep throat
in watergate and so this gives us a
whole new lens into how we want to think
about the fbi's relationship to
watergate its role in watergate um and
mark felt uh was there and sort of took
over the bureau at least in an
operational sense at the moment that
hoover died so there's a whole wealth of
new information about particular cases
um in its totality uh that's certainly
come out over the course of the last 20
25 years so that seemed appealing as
well but the main thing that appealed to
me about writing a new biography of j
edgar hoover really was interpretive and
wanting to take advantage of new strains
in scholarship that had come out over
those 20 years as well and really to
take hoover as i said from the margins
from being this figure of scandal being
seen as a rogue and a villain
and really think about what role he
played in shaping the american state in
shaping american politics in a much more
serious way and i think in a way
that is really suitable whether you like
him or you don't like him and i think at
this point most people myself included
don't particularly like him though i've
gotten to know him quite well
whether you like him or not it seems
like a moment in which he needs to be
taken seriously and thought about in
this in this broader way
i will say as i i mentioned that i'm not
going to go into great detail about this
so i'm happy to answer questions during
the q a
um about these questions about his
sexuality um and his kind of identity in
in that vein i will say that that is one
area of scholarship that seemed like it
was really ripe to kind of put the
pieces together to think about hoover
seriously
in ways that would be informed by
everything that's happened in queer
studies gay and lesbian studies as well
as in terms of gender studies thinking
about hoover
around the question of masculinity this
whole world of scholarship that's really
developed over the last 20 or 30 years
is incredibly useful for me in trying to
make sense of hoover in that vein
but today i'm going to stick to slightly
more formal politics i won't say that
that's not politics because i think that
it is in its own way
and i'm really going to talk about two
bodies of scholarly literature that have
been particularly useful to me and the
ways in which they've both informed my
understanding of hoover and then i think
the ways in which hoover also tells us
something new and interesting about
those bodies of scholarship
so i said
that the driving question of my project
in some ways
is really
how did an ideological conservative
maintain enormous state power build and
maintain enormous state power
during this period that we usually
conventionally describe as the heyday of
american liberalism
i'm going to shorten that slightly now
and just ask how did jay edgar hoover
maintain power for 48 years he was an
unelected bureaucrat
right so he had to be reappointed first
in his early years when it was not a
terribly powerful position by the
attorney general and then
by successive presidents uh he was there
under eight different presidents uh half
of them republicans half of them
democrats it's an incredibly long career
with an incredible amount of power so
how did this happen and i think the
conventional answer and in many ways the
kind of answer that we've gotten out of
this
expose tradition um is that people were
really scared of him
and i think in many ways for a very good
reason as i said you know a lot of what
we've learned about hoover over the last
30 or 40 years and to some degree knew
during his lifetime though not with the
detail that we know today
a lot of what we've learned are the ways
in which he used the fbi to
get people to do what he wanted
collecting uh you know sexual gossip on
people in washington uh collecting
details of people's lives running
disruption operations
against social movements as well as
against
to some degree as i said political
figures in washington as well um so
there's certainly a lot of truth to the
idea that hoover maintained his power
through fear and again to refer back to
the film j edgar which many of you uh
probably saw came out a year ago and i
think is a good kind of snapshot of
where thinking is at that point that
really was one of the big themes of the
film you know a lot of the film was was
leonardo dicaprio sort of in a darkened
room listening to the tapes of martin
luther king and you know kind of
obsessing about martin luther king
at any rate
there's a lot of truth to this story and
people have done magnificent research in
kind of ferreting out a lot more of the
truth than we once knew about j edgar
hoover but there are also a few problems
with this immediate assumption that
hoover held his power only through fear
and only because he had the goods on
powerful people
the first is that it doesn't really
explain to us how it is that he became
the man that he became uh when we think
about hoover having the goods on people
conducting those kinds of operations
we're really talking about 40s and the
50s really into the 1960s
um so how did he in fact become the man
that he became how did he acquire this
power in the first place in in the first
half of his career
and i think the second problem with this
immediate reversion to fear as our only
explanation for hoover's career and for
his power
is that it doesn't explain at least a
little bit of what we saw in that
funeral image of richard nixon standing
up there it doesn't explain hoover's
power as a public figure this kind of
mystical figure uh a household name and
um a kind of universally
universally known if uh never ever
universally loved figure and so i think
to answer those questions we really have
to think of hoover again not as a rogue
figure not as someone who's operating in
secrecy but as someone whose entire
career is deeply embedded within the
history of the administrative state and
the growth of government in the united
states um in some ways this seems like
okay well that's a little bit less
interesting than his secret files but i
think it's really critical to
understanding hoover and how he operated
and in fact i've come to conclude though
my editor is totally unpersuaded by this
when i say all of the drama is in the
bureaucracy
it's all in how the bureaucratic rules
were made and she says that is actually
not where the drama is that might be
what you think but nobody else is
actually going to think that so i am
here to make the case that uh if this is
not where all the drama is it is really
critical to understanding kind of how
hoover evolves as an architect and in
fact in some ways a recipient of a
certain kind of tradition of state power
um so
as i said so that's really the first
body of scholarly literature that i
think hoover's story needs to be
situated in this enormous profusion of
scholarship that's happened really since
the 1980s around the growth of the
administrative state kind of how did
in a democracy how did we get
an enormous federal government most of
which is entirely unelected and in many
cases uh relatively unaccountable to
electoral power and within that
literature the stuff that's particularly
useful to me
is the literature around the idea of
bureaucratic autonomy which is the
question of how is it that unelected
bureaucrats people like hoover agency
chiefs
manage to insulate themselves from an
electoral political system a political
system that evolves uh revolves around
parties and other kinds of power how do
they in fact achieve independent power
in independent political bases and in
hoover's case how do you end up with a
48-year career
so that's sort of the literature in
which i think we need to think about
hoover's the evolution of hoover's power
and in some ways he is kind of born to
this government tradition
he is an exact contemporary of figures
like robert moses right another kind of
who was the parks commissioner of new
york right another man who's sort of
born at the right time in the right
place to take advantage of a kind of
explosion of uh government power but
hoover himself is actually born in 1895
in washington dc he is born five blocks
from the u.s capitol um and he never
lives anywhere else so in this sense he
really is this pure product of
washington of washington politics and he
happens to be in the right place at the
right time as the government begins to
grow and particularly as the security
state begins to grow
his first job in the government is in
1917 as the u.s is having this enormous
expansion of government capacities in
world war one um and so they're just
hiring an entire generation of new young
people to come in um and to really
administer uh in that case the war
effort on a scale that has not been seen
before and in many ways hoover for the
first 20 years of his career is deeply
embedded in what many people would
describe as the expansion of the liberal
or the progressive state so putting
aside everything we know about who he
later becomes and to some degree putting
aside the role that he plays in the
first red scare of 1919 and 1920 which i
can talk about you know hoover really
comes to his appointment as bureau
director and then lasts through the
1920s and the 1930s on his reputation
for being an efficient bureaucrat for
being a professional for being divorced
from politics
many of the same themes and ideas that
led to the creation of other kinds of
state agencies and state bureaucracies
um so my argument i guess is that we
need to think about hoover again not
just as a figure who held
held power because he had the goods on
people but as someone who in many ways
was quite typical of the ways in which
state power was built whether you're
talking about a social welfare agency uh
whether you're talking to some degree
about the military though i think the
military is an exception but any of the
state agencies you see emerging in
washington um in the 20s but then really
in the 30s 40s and 50s i think we need
to understand hoover in that vein
the second thing that i will say about
the literature on bureaucratic autonomy
that i found particularly useful
is that hoover is a figure who is not
only very good at getting the goods on
people but he's a figure who knows how
to
use certain kinds of techniques of
bureaucracy internally and externally in
fact to give himself
an independent political base
so he runs an enormous propaganda
operation throughout much of his career
in which he understands that if he wants
to maintain his position if he wants to
maintain his agency's reputation he has
to appeal directly to a mass public on a
variety of themes some of which are
about professionalism some of which are
about law and order some of which are
kind of about detective mysteries and
the swashbuckling gman and some of which
are
overtly conservative but so he's very
effective at running that kind of
propaganda operation i think as
interestingly he's also very effective
at building his own political alliances
with grassroots organizations we don't
tend to think of jay edgar hoover in
that vein but particularly
kind of club-oriented conservative
organizations like the daughters of the
american revolution uh the american
legion etc they had very tight
relationships with the fbi they're sort
of back and forth relationships hoover
legitimated a lot of their interests
often helped these organizations out and
when he was in trouble they often came
to put pressure on congressmen and to
write letters to newspapers in defense
of j edgar hoover so i think we have to
think about him
as a political organizer as well my last
thing that i will say about j edgar
hoover as a bureaucrat is that i have
become convinced that the single most
important thing that he did in his
entire career in order to maintain power
was not in fact you know knowing about
john f kennedy's affairs or following
eleanor roosevelt and going to franklin
and reporting about who she uh in fact
was seeing the single most important
thing he did to maine power was to keep
his agents out of the civil service
system
he fought his entire career to keep his
agents out of civil service and what
this meant was that he was actually able
to build an agency in which he himself
had almost sole control over
the hiring the firing of agents the kind
of person he wanted
he justified this not on the grounds of
personal control but on the grounds of
saying that the fbi is so fabulous and
its standards are so high that they
simply cannot take the sort of mass of
people who are being recommended out of
the civil service but again these kinds
of bureaucratic questions these kinds of
state building questions i think are as
important for understanding j edgar
hoover
as um
what files he might have maintained so
that's sort of the first piece i said so
the driving force at least in part of
this biography is how does an
ideological conservative maintain state
power
throughout the age of american
liberalism so we've got a little bit of
the power story there i want to quickly
talk about the literature on
conservatism and just suggest a few ways
in which i think hoover tells us some
new and interesting things there
so again over the past 20 or so years
young historians in particular have
discovered that there's a whole history
to american conservatism uh when i right
before i started graduate school my
graduate advisor who was a
professor at columbia named alan
brinkley wrote an essay for our
professional journal uh that basically
started out saying
why doesn't anyone study the history of
american conservatism so this was 1994.
um you've gotten through the reagan
years but you just had uh you know newt
gingrich's revolution of 1994
conservatism is out there you sort of
put out this call and over the past 15
20 years there's been an explosion of
interest in kind of writing about
conservatism telling this story
without going into a lot of detail about
this the basic story that has emerged is
a story that tends to begin in the 1950s
to revolve both around social movements
organizations like the john birch
society and kind of elite figures like
william f buckley uh who gets his start
right here uh in the the 40s and 50s um
and tends to sort of tell a story of
this surge of uh conservative interest
of a self-defined conservative movement
kind of coming of age in its first
moment with the barry goldwater campaign
in 1964 and then kind of achieving
national power
in 1980 with ronald reagan um this is a
story where the pieces hadn't been put
together before and we've got a lot of
great literature out there about
different kinds of social movements that
play a role in that about the role of
business about the role of intellectuals
all sorts of things but i think that j
edgar hoover actually poses some new
questions for us as we begin to think
about this literature on conservatism
so the first thing that is that as i
said hoover is articulating the same
ideas in 1919 that he is articulating in
1972 now that this may just say
something about j edgar hoover uh as a
person uh who was in fact very rigid
very resistant to change but i think it
actually tells us something more
interesting and raises really
interesting questions about how we want
to think about the role that
conservatism has played
in modern american politics so hoover in
1972 is looking back to 1919 and saying
we're seeing the same thing we're seeing
these kinds of bombings we're seeing
disorder the same things that richard
nixon is saying in that little clip
that i showed j edgar hoover is already
beginning to use that language in the
teens in the 20s and in the 30s so i
think his story suggests that we want to
kind of break apart this story that
modern conservatism comes out of the
reaction to the new deal
and out of the 1950s
the second thing that i think hoover is
useful for thinking about is that as i
said a lot of the ways in which we tend
to think about conservative politics is
either an electoral frame or in a kind
of social movement frame right so you've
got the grassroots story
this kind of resurgence that begins in
the 50s into the 60s and 70s or you have
a kind of electoral politics story well
hoover is a very interesting figure in
this regard as i said he's actually
someone who is not sort of operating
outside the centers of washington power
he is deeply embedded in them throughout
this whole period
and i think it's interesting to consider
and i'll be happy to expand upon this in
the q a a little bit the interesting to
consider hoover as a kind of
conservative state builder so in what
ways do his conservative politics shape
what he does within his agency and in
what ways do his conservative politics
uh sort of shape the kind of message
that he is sending out into the world on
the third piece that i'll mention
quickly is that i think it's very
important to think about the fbi within
the context of this story of i don't
know a kind of battle between the left
and the right throughout these years or
between liberalism and conservatism
because the fact of j edgar hoover and
the kinds of politics that he had
actually meant that people on the ground
activists on the ground had very very
different relationships
to state power
it is fundamentally different experience
to be organizing on the left
and we all probably basically know the
story of the fbi's relationship with the
new left with the black panthers with
the anti-war movement right it's a
fundamentally different experience to
fear that your organization is being
infiltrated uh to
know that the federal government is
watching you and is against you uh than
it is to be organizing even uh on in a
similar grassroots organization
on the right and know that in some sense
the fbi is behind you that j edgar
hoover is basically tolerant or
supportive of your politics now i don't
think this explains
everything certainly about what's going
on in social movements but to the degree
that we are talking in the 1960s now
about a kind of battle that's emerged
between the left and the right during
those years i think it's important to
see that their relationships with the
state and with the fbi in particular are
not equivalent and that they're very
different on the ground experiences in
part
because of this man who is there
at the top
in the fbi
all right just to finish up i want to
say a few things going back to our our
nixon at jagger hoover's funeral i said
you know the things that stood out to me
about that clip were number one
the fact of the funeral right the fact
that this unelected bureaucrat
was able to
bring together the kind of power and
interest and cultural influence that
hoover did in 1972 and in the years
leading up to that um the second was
that he stood for something right he
stood for a particular kind of
conservative politics and really was a
bulwark of that kind of conservative
politics throughout this period we
describe as the age of american
liberalism
the third piece that i just want to say
that i mentioned at the beginning and
want to expand upon very briefly
is just how much hoover's image has
changed since that moment now certainly
there were lots of people who hated j
edgar hoover throughout his life but i
think there's something to be explained
in just how dramatically uh his image
has changed over the last 40 years
and probably the best embodiment of this
for me is that in 1975 this is three
years after he died the fbi finally got
its own building on pennsylvania avenue
it had been within the justice
department's building previous to that
and when the fbi got its own building
it was labeled the j edgar hoover
building it was put up as this kind of
great monument to the great man who had
built the bureau
today they are actually probably going
to knock down that building because it's
kind of a monstrosity you know like mid
70s terrible architecture looks kind of
like the old new haven coliseum
so you can see so they are probably
going to move out of this building
and there is an almost universal
assumption that when they move out of
that building and when they knock that
building down you know the next fbi
building is not going to be called
the j edgar hoover building and in fact
there have been battles over the last 15
to 20 years to actually have his name
stripped off of the fbi building that is
still standing there so i think on the
one hand this is the product of what i
was saying earlier right we do know more
about him right we've had these exposes
we know more about the lawlessness and
the corruption um and the real vanality
that the fbi was engaged in over that
time but i think it's important to
historicize our own thoughts as well so
i'll just leave you with a couple of
reasons
why i think j edgar hoover's image has
changed so much going beyond the fact
that we just know some more of the
really problematic things that were
going on
the first is that hoover happened to die
at a moment of expose right he happened
to die as watergate is beginning to take
off and this really comes to fruition
with things like the church committee
and with other exposes of the cia of
other intelligence agencies and new
constraints on intelligence agencies and
in that context i do think
probably deservedly so hoover emerged as
something of a scapegoat as a person
upon whom you could say
oh look at all of those terrible
terrible things that happened well
there's the man who did them and now
he's dead and he was a very very bad man
and none of the rest of us actually have
to take this too seriously or think
about taking responsibility for it
ourselves so i think it has both served
you know truth
but has also had the effect of kind of
absolving other people of a certain kind
of responsibility and limiting the
degree to which we're going to think in
broader terms it was just that one bad
apple that very powerful apple that bad
apple
i think the second thing that's worth
thinking about
is why people have become increasingly
interested in uh hoover's sex life
and
you know i mean it's inherently pretty
interesting on the one hand um on the
other hand it is actually i think also a
product of a pretty profound shift
that's happened in how we think about
our public officials
and i think to some degree for the
better and to some degree for uh the
worse in the sense that you know not
only did we not know a lot about j edgar
hoover's sex life at the time but we
didn't know a lot about what a whole lot
of other powerful people uh were doing
in their intimate relationships and so
on the one hand it has this kind of
scandalous
and interesting quality to it on the
other hand i think we do have to think
about hoover in relationship to
a broader culture which has begun to
take seriously i think for good reasons
and for bad
the the
personal lives of its public figures and
how we want to uh put those pieces
together um so i see that i'm actually
i've run a little bit over my prescribed
time which was 40 minutes so
i think i will actually just leave it
there for now but last thing that i want
to say is that overall one of the
challenges of writing about hoover
is that i am trying to write a biography
that takes him seriously and really
looks at his power and his influence
takes his personal life his childhood
seriously
at the same time without writing a
redemptive biography of a man who i
think in many ways had a very very
destructive influence on the united
states and on the shape of its political
culture and on the shape of american
government so i will leave it there for
now hopefully we can do some questions
recently in which a person called jerry
and berger one of the great american
people
a patriot can be a conservative and the
patriot can be a liberal
um
i've always suspected that he had no
political belief but that he is found to
be
a dictator
not necessarily a national dictator but
a dictator in his own world and
dictators always
suggest
that people are coming in from the
outside undermining the state and the
only thing about hitler or today
president assad as well as the outsiders
coming in and that's what helps to build
up a kind of dictatorship
so did he really have political beliefs
or was he merely a narcissistic power
ground
well yes and yes uh so the question is
was jagger hoover a narcissistic power
grabber or did he have genuine political
beliefs um and i think the the challenge
of writing about him is that these
things are simultaneously true um the
question was sort of centered around the
idea that dictators tend to
describe kind of hold and maintain
maintain power by describing subversive
forces that are about to invade and then
defending the population from these
from these subversive forces internal or
external so is hoover any more
complicated than that and i think that
he actually is i think that the
consistency of his uh outlook over time
and particularly the role that he ends
up playing um
especially around the question of
communism but not exclusively around the
question of communism in articulating it
not only as a kind of national security
threat but going significantly beyond
that to talk about and write about and
publish bestsellers about uh godless
communism the threat of atheistic
communism i mean hoover wrote about the
traditional family he wrote about
religion uh he was active in the boy
scouts and in kind of you know manly
politics bringing up our men to be good
citizens uh this sort of stuff so
actually his view
is on the one hand very consistent over
time um and on the other hand i think
slightly broader than we generally
understand it to be so he really does
have this kind of
cultural force and it is absolutely true
that throughout his career i mean the
question of power and who's going to be
in control of the situation and who's
going to be in control of his
bureaucracy are almost always the
dominant issues but there are moments in
which he actually also
makes decisions that put the fbi at a
certain amount of risk for what he
understands to be ideological reasons
particularly around the question of
communism
you alluded to some of the reasons why
there might be
this interest
these days in his
sexuality
do you think that
some of that has to do with
um you know in this area we took down
gay rights
over that the
impulse that we see today on the modern
left to
kind of out and to criticize
conservative figures who you know
who defend traditional values and
and and attack you know sexually deviant
you know individuals while themselves
being sexually deviant
of congressmen
right yes so the question is uh to what
degree is the interest in hoover
sexuality about um an impulse to expose
hypocrisy essentially i mean
particularly within the gay rights
movement uh to out people who are in
power uh particularly people who spend a
lot of time uh either citing family
values or in fact you know persecuting
people for their sexual deviancy at the
same time how did you put you had a very
nice way of putting it at the same time
that they themselves are engaged in all
sorts of
sexual deviancy of one sort or another
um i absolutely think that this is uh
hoover's
type right and one of the things that is
really interesting that i'm trying to
sort out and i would love to hear uh
people in this room is that there does
seem to be i mean certainly this is
something that we see playing out in our
own politics today but particularly in
the 1950s it seems uh that there is this
strange strange mess meshing of kind of
anti-communism and anti-homosexuality
and it's very well established that at
the same time that a red scare is going
on in the 1940s and 1950s there's what's
we're now calling the lavender scare
in which actually more homosexuals than
communists are being purged from
government jobs are being seen as
national security risks particularly
within the state department but within a
whole variety of government agencies at
that point
and at the same time many of the figures
who are most deeply engaged in this are
themselves being accused of being
homosexual and in some cases
we know very well a figure like roy cohn
you know in fact who was
worked on the mccarthy committee sort of
infamous figure of that time if you've
ever seen angels in america right we
have roy cohn they're exactly fitting
this type and there are a number of men
in hoover circle in the 40s and 50s who
do seem to fit into that framework so
you know the question is how do we put
all of those pieces together right are
they actively defending themselves and
their own positions um and kind of going
to extremes in order to defend
themselves from these accusations right
that seems to be part of it how exactly
uh the questions of communism and
homosexuality fit in uh in a piece for
these men i think is a very interesting
question what kind of world are they
themselves living in and we have little
snippets of information i mean one of
the things that's actually particularly
interesting about hoover's relationship
with clyde tolson is that in some sense
it was extremely public right we have
this idea that they were these closeted
men and on the one hand they were they
would have denied to the ends of the
earth
that they were homosexual at least they
would have denied that publicly on the
other hand they spent 40 years together
traveling together having dinner to dig
together every night kind of going to
each other's family funerals being
really a very functional and
well-recognized social couple in
washington so i think there's a lot of
stuff that's going on in this moment and
i think uh there are two things i mean
one i'm not sure that pure
just a story of hypocrisy really gets to
the root of this i think there are
probably
more interesting things to do with it
and i think that we also have to try to
kind of historicize these questions and
things look very different in the 1930s
than they look in the 1950s around those
kinds of questions and they look
different
again in the 1970s though we can as you
noted see these continuities of of type
over time
have you consciously avoided the
language of psychology or psychology i
would have called him deeply paranoid
yes so this is this is one of the great
biographical questions right and the
question of psychobiography and where to
go i mean hoover is a very very
interesting figure on this account i
mean many people are so first of all
there's a lot of real diagnosed mental
illness in his family
his father actually dies of you know
it's a little hard to tell but but
depression he's he's institutionalized
when hoover is a teenager and dies of
some combination of depression maybe
maybe alcoholism but his death
certificate actually says that he dies
of melancholia which is depression
and the secondary cause of death is in
amnition which means that he basically
lost the will to live stopped eating and
kind of just
faded away and starved to death so i
mean so there is there is deep mental
illness and real diagnosed mental
illness uh in hoover's family um and
then more broadly right there are these
questions about uh words like paranoia
which is a kind of psychological term
but not not a diagnosis of sorts i mean
it's very clear that actually hoover as
an older man
um he's always a very very rigid person
right and he's very as you can imagine
he's he likes the rules right and if you
have a typo
in your fbi report you're going to get a
letter back and this is from the moment
that he's a young man for uh until till
the day he dies you're going to get a
two-page letter back from j edgar hoover
saying you have betrayed
me right this is unthinkable this is
unspeakable how can we have this level
of chaos and disorder within our own
agency i mean i'm exaggerating a little
bit but but not a lot
and this level of rigidity really only
increases as he becomes um an older man
so putting together the question of kind
of how personality meets
political structure and political
ideology you know it's it's a challenge
i'm not sure i have a perfect answer to
the question but it's one that i clearly
have to sort out yeah
two questions who was the man that the
camera zoomed in on at the funeral was
that tulsa you know i was trying to i i
saw that i think that was el patrick
gray who had been appointed by
nixon to be hoover's successor at the
fbi this is one of the things that
becomes
a source of disorder during the during
watergate is that he appointed an
outsider
instead of an insider and then the
second one in terms of how uber stayed
in power
during the heyday of liberalism isn't
part of the answer that it was a certain
it was cold war liberalism
so it was not the kind of liberalism
that follows basically after his death
in 72. so he was always on the right
side whether the
administration was republican or
democratic they were all on the same
side of
the cold war i think that's true in part
although there are many moments where
you know someone like harry truman is
not particularly enthused about j edgar
hoover and hoover actually
um they really come to blows truman
wants to fire hoover he feels like he
cannot fire hoover and the reasons that
he cannot fire hoover are in part uh
because you know hoover's a powerful man
with files but really often and kennedy
says the same thing because he's so
popular he's so popular and they feel
like it would just be such a political
disaster for themselves to fire him so i
think that's absolutely right and hoover
was actually very good at cultivating
people like franklin roosevelt who
really of any president is the person
who empowers hoover they're in the 20s
and 30s there are pretty serious
restrictions on what the fbi can do um
and it's during the second world war and
a little bit earlier as well that it's
franklin roosevelt who comes and says
you know we've got to keep an eye on
communists we've got to keep an eye on
fascists and and kind of gives hoover
this power
so yeah
that the the content of hoover's
conservatism as you've described it is
um
not uh not anti-radical in the sense of
being anything about private property or
free markets or anything like this but
really a profound americanism and the
enemy being things he perceives to be
anti-americanism but so it's interesting
that you that he comes from washington
dc because i think about that ideology
as sort of like quintessentially
american midwest right and you know you
think of joe mccarthy as someone who
in a similar vein you know it's about
communism but it's not really about
communism it's about america and uh you
know there's a sort of petty bourgeois
uh element to his ideological project
and nixon probably fits that bill too so
what i was just wondering if you could
say a little bit about hoover's
upbringing and who his parents are and
what what is the milieu that he's coming
up in that he is so
feels this strong need to protect a
particular vision of american culture
which is what it sounds like he
is the thing he feels is under threat
right right well i think i'm supposed to
not go on at great length at this point
but i'll say quickly two things so one i
think it's very true right to the degree
that sort of conventional wisdom would
suggest that the main strains of kind of
mid-century conservatism are
anti-communism a kind of traditional
uh protestant religious cultural strain
sometimes fundamentalists sometimes
somewhat short of that
as and uh oh and a kind of free
enterprise libertarian strain right
these are all competing with each other
we might add the question of
race in there and put that in as a
fourth strain or one that overlaps with
all of these right the one that hoover
absolutely doesn't really occupy is the
kind of libertarian strain right is a
free enterprise strain uh he is an
architect of the state right i mean he's
a big government guy in his own way um
and so i think the to the degree that
that's become really a dominant strain
on the american right now i think it
also helps to explain why the right
really doesn't claim j edgar hoover
anymore i mean why nobody claims jfk
hoover
at this point outside of fairly limited
circles um the question of his childhood
is interesting so his father is a
government servant i mean everyone in
his family are government servants of
one sort or another but very kind of
mid-level government servants his father
is a
is a um
works at the coast survey he's a printer
um and his father had worked at the
coast survey and they're an old
washington family from the early 19th
century and he grows up in a kind of you
know presbyterian protestant tradition
so i'm not sure that you can look
so much to his childhood for these kinds
of ideological
uh ideological concepts i mean i think
he's really shaped by world war one uh
and the the red scare after it and this
is the moment in which his politics are
established and those politics really
last and so to that degree this concept
of americanism or 100 americanism that
is so much a strain of that moment i
think lasts for him
well terrific i've got two thanks and
two invitations
first i want to thank beverly for the
fabulous talk very stimulating obviously
the audience enjoyed it tremendously
thank you all for coming and ask me so
many great questions
and my two invitations are number one to
come to our reception which is next door
in the comments room where you'll be
able to ask everybody some additional
questions and then to come back for our
next two
company of scholars lectures the next
one is about
families and upbringing of families of
the united states
ladies
stand up you're going to be next
and the last one
seems to be divergent because it's by
paul tipton on the higgs boson
which is a great scientific discovery in
the last year but his theme is actually
about whether the taxpayers of all the
countries in the world got their money
before
uh discovering the
as well so thank you all for coming